German prosecutors have charged
Volkswagens former CEO Martin Winterkorn
with serious fraud
that's over his part in the diesel
emissions cheating scandal that engulfed
Volkswagen and other car makers
Winterkorn is the first auto company
boss to be charged over the scandal in
Germany and Rob watts is here in the
studio with us from DW business to break
all of this down for us so what exactly
is he accused of brother so and you
mentioned they're serious fraud well
actually the prosecutors of use of words
particularly serious fraud in relation
to this case he's charged alongside four
others we don't actually know who those
four others are but he's also accused of
not only the fraud but of breaking
competition rules as you mentioned the
first automotive boss to be charged in
Germany over the diesel emissions
scandal and that's what this is all
about let's just remind ourselves
exactly what that was so the diesel
emission scandal was the use of software
by the likes of VW to make their cars
appear to be emitting fewer harmful
chemicals during testing than they
actually did when they were out on the
road and what it's thought is that VW
sold something like 10 million cars
between 2007 and 2015 that had this
cheating software installed what mr.
vinta corn is accused of is knowing
about this sooner than he let on I mean
he resigned more or less immediately
after the scandal broke in 2015 but
prosecutors in Germany of today said
they think he knew about this as early
as 2014 but didn't let anyone know and
it's not the only legal trouble that
he's in is it no it's not so we
mentioned he's been charged in Germany
which is actually also facing charges in
America where this has been a very big
deal there he's being sued VW is also
being sued but there is particular focus
on Martin Winterkorn there they don't
want him to ever be allowed to run
another organization that has operations
in the US ever again
but he was unlikely to actually face
trial in the US because Germany has a
habit of not extraditing in fact has a
rule
not extraditing its citizens but now
he's been charged in Germany itself he
may well end up having that day in court
so walk us through now what happens next
not only for Winterkorn but also for VW
yes for VW this is yet more bad press
it's the scandal that won't go away
they're clearly very keen to draw a line
under it it's cost them billions of
euros just last year actually
prosecutors in Germany at find them a
billion euros over the scandal but in
the u.s. they've also had fines of
around 20 billion euros so they're
desperate to break free of this as you
might expect martin vinter Cornwell the
prosecutors have said today that he
faces between six months and ten years
behind bars if he is convicted of these
charges he also faces having any bonuses
that he made as a result if the sale was
made over those years being withdrawn
from him okay so a big day when it comes
to accountability for the
emissions-cheating scandal first time
that we've seen a top boss like this
charged with in germany rob watts
breaking it down for us thanks so much